dominic cummings damning testimony
describes a chaotic government
ill-prepared to face a global pandemic
he told the committee the prime minister
played down the threat describing
reports
as scare stories we already know the
prime minister headed off on a working
holiday mid-february
and mr cummings said today some other
senior ministers were off skiing
during this critical stage of the
pandemic we know too that boris johnson
missed
the first five cobra meetings on kovid
19.
on a third of march the prime minister
was still boasting
about shaking hands i'm shaking hands
continuously
i was at a hospital the other night
where i think there were a few there
were actually a few coronavirus
patients and i shook hands with
everybody uh you'll be pleased to know
one of the most controversial pandemic
debates has been around
herd immunity and if it was indeed
government policy
what has become clearer today is that it
was
certainly a government assumption and
desired
despite recent denials from number 10
on the 12th of march the uk entered the
delay phase which the government hoped
would slow the spread of covert and push
the peak of infections away
from the winter on the same day the
prime minister
made a grim warning many more families
he said
are going to lose loved ones on the 13th
of march sir patrick valens appeared on
sky news
here's what he said about herd immunity
i mean what sort of percentage of people
need to have contracted the virus
probably about 60 percent or so
and we think that this virus is likely
to be one that comes back year on year
become like a seasonal virus and
communities will become
immune to it three days later the delay
policy was dropped and the country moved
towards the first national lockdown on
the 23rd
of march one of the biggest scandals in
the pandemic has been the failure to
protect the elderly in care homes
here's what matt hancock told a press
conference in may
we try to build infection control
and the support and the protective ring
around care homes
right from the start dominic cummings
said today the government rhetoric of
throwing a shield around care homes
was complete nonsense and this evidence
corroborates a sky news report broadcast
on the 6th of april
that elderly patients were being
discharged into care homes
without being tested and allowing the
disease to spread with devastating
consequences
today dominic cummings also touched on
the second lockdown he claimed today
if he had resigned in september and put
pressure on the prime minister
to lock down sooner then tens of
thousands of people would still be alive
by the 6th of october sage documents
show in
england the number of infections and
hospital admissions
is exceeding reasonable worst case
scenario
planning on october 31st boris johnson
is forced to announce the second
national lockdown mr cummings said
this is when he heard the prime minister
say he would rather see bodies pile high
than impose another lockdown this is the
testimony of one man but it does
ask searching question of the
government's response to this crisis
the truth may only emerge once there is
a full
public inquiry into the pandemic